that was uh at Bert's house wasn't it
yeah yeah yeah he was like a series from
New York she flew with it yeah I was
flying on tour I was like I just got an
idea I'm like I'm gonna give somebody
Molly on a podcast I don't know who
how'd you transport it up my ass yeah no
I always like to hear how people
transport drugs you know they ain't
looking
it's dumb they ain't looking for that
[ __ ] yeah I mean dude to be fair it's
not like a like a you know pass-out-able
amount it's just like a little bit what
what I um noticed over the years was
that going through security like like
whatever they look at whatever they saw
money like they were like oh no no you
you keep your cash like I don't want to
yeah
like the keeping drugs in cash money
yeah that's pretty smart which I kind of
did anyway I don't know if you have like
Coke or something you like pull it into
a dollar and like kept twisting it up
how much how much blood do you think
you've
eight times
ah I didn't fly that much with like real
narcotics but but whatever the problem
with Coke is like it's always a like hey
you want you want blow you're like yeah
okay but it's not a I I better have some
blow on me like weed you're like I I
gotta fly with some weed cause I'll need
it right I don't feel like I'm never
gonna do this again so it's fine I got
to a point where I needed the coke oh
really yeah I definitely needed it like
I could not fly without it well you're
like Elton John like where you woke up
in the morning and snorted blow
and then you can function no
I mean not like wake up in the morning
no I'd like uh you just do a whip it
right when you woke up yeah I mean
whatever underrated drug it's nitrous
whippets it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're at ranked number
30 on all of Amazon and if you buy a
bottle we might go up the ladder and
that would mean a lot so please get on
Amazon and buy Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole yeah
yeah dude